my smartphone is one of my most personal
possessions until now I thought my
secret code was enough to protect it I
don't want to see it fall into the hands
of a stranger or frankly even the people
I'm close to it has my photos my emails
my texts my appointments my contacts
even the secret recipe for my favorite
soup if somebody collects four unique
location data points from you they can
98% of the time actually identify you
personally my phone and your phone is
going to be different because our
patterns of usage are totally different
the only I go to my home in my office
and like the same coffee shop every day
and so even though those data points on
their own can be described as anonymous
in fact the totality of the data is not
anonymous
we both have apps that know when were
active and for how long how we engage
with those things that leaves a trace
the number of apps that I have on my
phone versus the number of apps that you
have on your phone that also leaves a
trace if your city is constantly being
filmed
and senses are tracking you as you walk
around with your mobile phone are you
more or less likely to attend a protest
are you more or less likely to go into
the street and have your voice heard
about something that might be
oppositional to your government and one
of the things that happened in the
Ukraine earlier this year during a
peaceful protest is that thousands of
people walking in the street and
peaceful protest to get the same text
message that said you have been
registered as an illegal participant in
a street protest now that's a pretty
terrifying thing to get because what it
means is that first of all you are being
tracked
you are being observed and that your
participation has been recorded how does
that change the way you might want to
engage in protest in future that has a
serious or has at least the risk of
being a serious chilling effect what are
the things were having some kind of
anonymity or at least some kind of
ability to not permanently be recorded
what do we lose if you give that up the
Mormon applications no need the better
they work this is exactly what Randy
says Frances leading thinker on data
collection 2000 visual effects
equivalent by example at initialization
a particular Cal over in the determine a
lizard should do additional a series of
always consumer of a quasi survey didn't
abandon Lexi dormant
panco that adjudication on 11/11 Texan a
broker series important due to Poisson
Texaco effects of a tomato preservation
spa
Novus upon deformation Calabria dr.
Rocca Mustafa Denis strongest natural
charcoal a patent from Conde de vous
avec le de Rueda Tantra Chris Eden
critical addressed nomination even more
so at a publisher Southwest regarded by
the personally prepare a relationship
it's a horizontal Sedona now affected
only movie on Morton calamity
misinformation Transpo avec de mettre
federal human context daughter care
should hold on to you
the attitudes of context tradition
culture can you imagine if we let the
police spy on us the way our phones do i
tried almost every possible way to get
out of mobile phone tracking i set up a
fake meme I got a fake phone under that
fake name so that I could carry a phone
that wasn't attached to my identity but
I found that basically I go to the same
places and I make all the same calls so
ultimately the fake identity wasn't
masking that much because in fact what's
they attracted my behavior more than my
identity right the behavior is Mitel and
so therefore that was impossible to
conceal if i wanted to use a phone
because the phone is constantly
transmitting to all sorts of people and
i don't have an ability to sort of say
oh yes to this connection and no to that
one it's sort of a binary on off the
phone is either on and it's transmitting
to all these people who i can't control
or it's off and I can't get any calls
and the problem is I know mother I have
two children and I kind of need to be
reachable if you want to have a phone in
today's world which is basically not
optional you have to be tracked and you
don't have a lot of opportunities to
turn it off and so that's why it's not
about personal choice it's not that I
made the choice to give up my privacy
it's that we as a society have not set
any limits on the type of tracking that
can happen
and so what we see is this battle
between the industries over who can
track us and the sad thing is that we as
citizens there doesn't seem to be a
proposal like hey how about nobody with
everything our phones to know about us
it seems like the future belongs to big
data which is exactly what we'll explore
in the next episode of do not trap see
you later you know that game would you
rather would you rather have two foam
arms or be constantly followed
everywhere by tiny ducklings